hello and welcome to this video playing
Rick Stephan looks like a mainline we
Lopez got mine my line got 318 on the
clock that's funny
but not uncommon I've had tournament
games where I've spent no time actually
at that line only the increment
yeah I've got this regrouping plan
nights to g7 + f7 Bishop to d7 and then
slowly slowly prepare five possible okay
yeah I'm still going for this yeah but
he was tempted by Luka a seven but that
doesn't lead anywhere
I had this on the board so often that's
it's really it's kind of kind of weird
yeah he knows the cup of game everybody
knows this idea that's a it's a it's a
good one it's a good idea often at least
it's a good idea so let's think about it
a little bit so how do we handle this a
couple of ideas I want one idea is to
bring the Bishop to b6 which is it's
possible that's possible
France funnier ll occurrence gun under a
file but what exactly is her chewing
okay I know don't get me wrong I'm not
making fun of what he's doing I'm just
other thing that look at that I just
think it looks funny it has a weird
aesthetic to it okay so one idea here is
you do something myself on the kingside
okay so got one rook traded I mean my
experience with this line is just if you
get the rooks of the board you are okay
absolutely okay with black as in the
long run you get to get you get to play
you get to play a five yeah I'm so just
playing for this idea to trade the rooks
he cannot really prevent that Bishop z8
we should be seven Luke aid impossible
almost impossible to stop
okay
once the Queen's off I have some
additional ideas one key idea is that
with one key ideas to play the bishop to
age six to trade it off yeah I don't
mind he's basically just losing time him
the bishop to age six and once that is
traded then you can ultimately try to
play a five and I know it sounds
probably a little bit outlandish if you
don't know this line but quite often you
sacrifice pieces on d5 for porn Rolla I
have won many games with this idiom
white can sometimes sacrifice on C form
maybe he's trying to do that it's yeah
that could could be an idea it could be
an idea
I mean it's wrong it is always an idea I
mean it could work here maybe because
with Bishop f8 no it seems his shelf
this idea for the moment okay so I can
go here
now I'm on d5 and sometimes you can
sacrifice on d5 and then have a really
strong pawn roller
okay now let's let's see if I can get in
King g5 ok he's stopping that now at
five it's possible right yeah that's a
good moment because he cannot take here
now as default joke actually interesting
so now I can take on d5 just wonder if
there is a difference how I take
[Music]
take this you had this Pamela on 94 I
got d5 which is the thread anyway g5
okay it's got 96
okay it's not that's not exactly ideal
but oh I did not I did not evaluate this
right 96 is indeed a possibility but
okay I can do this okay now I see I can
do this and have this square covering v5
and now now just let's win this friggin
porn
sometimes nights are really strong don't
need to take
see 3d 3d three maybe
see three coming
just trying to avoid all kind of counter
blame it just has no way to save all the
pawns yeah so I mean as as I mentioned I
have had this on the board a million
times and one thing one thing that is
clear
that's if we jump into some of those
positions yeah one of those positions it
is very interesting to also look at the
engine evaluation it always gives white
a pretty big advantage like one pawn and
this is really not that clear if this is
if this is true I mean if black manages
to trade off the heavy pieces he's got
very few things to worry about as we
have seen this is what happened and it's
it's difficult to avoid once the a file
is open he tried to play the cop of
maneuver the bishop a7 maneuver that was
played in that famous game cup of
Windsor come nitsa on this 1974 but yeah
I mean it's okay but it doesn't help it
doesn't help the difference to the
windseeker game is that windseeker had a
far worse piece position once again a
knight on b7 which was bad and so on and
this is not the case him it is actually
quite difficult for y2 to make any
headway f5 suggested by the compas
counterplay I know this is possible but
in a blitz game I prefer to play the
quick moves that I know
to be okay and I know if I'm just
playing for the further traits of the
heavy pieces I'm just totally fine and
he didn't really he didn't avoid it yeah
so it finally happened and here I know
I'm okay because white is basically down
to that peace sacrifice idea on C form
for the two pawns and my plan is to
trade this off and ultimately play some
f5 as we have seen in the game so he did
not manage to avoid the trade so here
this is interesting
taking on C form that is an interesting
question if that works I don't think so
but it is it is interesting to check so
how mid the night usually you want to
take with Knights because the bishop the
bishops tend to support the pawns better
so now him a bishop yeah it's not easy
to say if this is actually good because
that could be too slow now this is the
engines giving is 0 which is suspicious
yeah that could also be bad for black
and it's it's very slow ish night c7
looks better
it's probably not fully convincing for
wider the pawns arm
I'm not going this quickly but it's
interesting it's very interesting to do
ok night b1 bishop age 6 get this traded
and now this is on c7 covering this and
preparing the sacrifice and yeah I took
a long time my experience is that the
knight is best on e7 because it has the
two options here and f5 so this okay I
tried this one just again and now King
III is helping me of course I'm stepping
into f5 so f5 and now it's a problem I'm
threatening this I'm threatening this
and if he takes he's got this additional
weakness to worry about they took with
the Jeep on so what would have happened
if he had not done this so let's say he
plays 92 game this is a better better
solution so f5 probably g5 and now it's
the moment where you have to think about
sacrificing does that really work here
probably probably not yeah I mean this
is interesting but I think f4 is the
problem I don't want to advance and I
don't want to take my engine gives the
gifts it's about equal yeah that's tough
maybe if I play this and then age six
that could be interesting but I never
get a knight to f7 or age seven
yeah but but I can actually do this like
h6 white white stasium mimes and in from
age 7 I would actually I would actually
attack this so is there not a way to
regroup this to age 7 so let's say if if
Y does just shuffling him yeah does it
only now see the from like at this let
me take here and here and now 97f at age
7 isn't that a problem okay he's just in
time to cover it with night age 3 ok so
then this doesn't work yeah I mean in a
blitz game um you probably want to make
the sacrifice maybe age 6 first that is
an idea M this then take on G 5 and then
sacrifice so that G 5 is potentially
weak thinking about this maybe f4 that
isn't even good so okay here there right
there are some ideas here yeah um
King III f5 and now it's it's basically
over this is falling apart
for too many threads yeah night c8 I can
just take Knight f5 oh that's stupid I
mean this this keeps a big advantage but
it wasn't the best possible way to play
yeah and here you just have to be have
to be good technically okay
oh I had deformed that was that was a
strong move the ideas that I have
that was stronger than night age five
then and in fact seven is still a game
this is this is this is interesting he
can actually promote king cakes Knight
takes behind and then the pinned wow
that is a totally outlandish line
thankfully I'm still better but it would
have been a shock yeah okay in the game
I think nothing nothing much happened so
um yeah this is an you think one thing
to take take from from this game is I
mean I've have played this so often with
black there are no ideas and ending and
if you find an opening that you can
examine in such depth and and in detail
where you know ideas up to the ending
and this is a very dangerous weapon
simply because you will know much more
than the opponent and have just
oftentimes a huge advantage timewise
yeah you you just get get the ideas
quicker and can better learn you wait
what's going on okay guys thanks for
watching